[Music]
from this determination is developed a
moral view of the world which consists
in the relation between the absoluteness
of morality and the absoluteness of
nature this relation is based on the one
hand on the complete indifference and
independence of nature towards moral
purposes in activity and on the other
hand on the consciousness of Duty alone
as the essential fact and of nature is
completely devoid of Independence and
essential being the moral view of the
world consists in the development of the
moments which are present in this
relation of such completely conflicting
presuppositions
here in paragraph 600 we are seeing
Hegel working out an insight that is is
not unique to him but I think is there
quite a bit
in previous German idealists namely that
the moral view on the world is going to
involve a relation a connection but see
home B between two different let's call
it not just points of view but but
substantial realities substantial not in
the sense of being substances but rather
as being what determines matters and one
of these is nature the entire world as
we know it including our basic drives
our passions whatever psychological laws
can be given about those and then this
realm of morality which is not the only
realm of freedom here so this is a bit
different than say can't write where
can't counter poses the realm of nature
which is almost you know you could say
purely determined by laws that can be
understood in a mechanistic fashion and
then a new mental realm of freedom and
somehow these two interpenetrate Hegel
is trying to grasp this in a more
adequate way that this problematic so
he's going to tell us that from this
determination this beast Immel right
this this determination discussed in the
previous paragraph about these two
different domains is developed or you
might say works itself out I was
building is the the verb there a moral
view of the world a moral Deltan xiaolin
of a moral grasp on the totality of
everything so from this this you know
relation this connection this
determination and he says this consists
the relation relation between what now
notice what he's going to say here the
absoluteness of morality and the
absoluteness of nature we have two
absolutes can we preserve two absolutes
and play for very long can there really
be this sort of shared divvying up of
the realm of the absolute or is there
something about the absolute that
requires us to make it one absolute a
unity can either of them really be
absolute if they're limiting each other
it's a really central problem here isn't
it
so he goes on and he says it consists in
the relation between the absoluteness of
morality and the absolutes of nature so
what is this relation he says the
relationship is based on the one hand
and then on the other so he's going to
tell us how it appears from each side
let's pause here for a moment
notice that what's happening here is as
so often we have the consciousness that
we're observing which is a consciousness
itself engaged in observation engaged in
willing engaged in developing itself
that doesn't really see the whole
picture and then we have us as the
observing consciousness the
phenomenologist charting out how these
go because we're saying that we can look
at it from both of these points of view
the moral consciousness can really only
look at it from this point of view at
this point in time so he goes on and he
says it's based on the one hand on the
complete indifference and independence
of nature towards something we'll talk
about towards what in just a moment but
the complete indifference gleich Ghul t
kite you know as a that's a indifference
is a great way to express it everything
is just as good as everything else you
know this piece of chalk just as good as
this piece of chalk they're both going
to work the same way on the chalk
because they're both governed by the
same laws they're both gonna fall at the
same rate because gravity is gonna
affect them in the same way we could go
on and on and on and it doesn't matter
whether I feel that one of them is
somehow more morally important I mean I
don't know it'd make a piece of chalk
more morally significant or salient but
let's assume that there was any
possibility nature would say I don't
care I operate the way I operate I don't
care about what about your Hegel goes on
and he says about moral purposes it's
vak all right and activity doesn't also
even care about duty moral duty that's
stuff for the side of morality nature
doesn't care about that now you can say
well you know but maybe evolutionary
biology you know shows us that we
naturally you know congregate together
because it there's an evolutionary
advantage to doing that we come to
recognize that things are good they're
good for the group are really good for
us and we should do then there's a
process of Association and that's fine I
mean that's not a new viewpoint Hume had
something similar Herbert Spencer who
nobody reads anymore these days was
saying those things way back in the
1800s
and then there were people saying well
that's kind of BS even back then but
that's kind of immaterial Hegel's not
interested in psychological laws at this
point get of all you one of those in in
nature over here but those don't
actually get to moral purposes moral
duties moral activities this is one of
the things count was pointing out to us
in criticizing what he called you
diamond ISM all right okay let's go out
and a little bit further so he says we
have a complete indifference and
independence right zelfs dendy kite now
this is an interesting thing because
independence you know could have been
arraigned arranged with a different
you know here it's standing on its own
there's a more positive sense than not
being dependent an extending case you
know or something like that so nature is
its own sphere it does its own things it
doesn't care about the absoluteness of
morality as a matter of fact it doesn't
even register it what about the side of
the absoluteness of morality says on the
other hand the consciousness of Duty
alone as the essential fact as what
matters if you do in fact take the moral
point of view
you're not prioritizing duty in there
and saying let me order things so so
duty is good and fulfilling nature
that's good to put nature down here
except maybe it might corrupt they're
gonna creep up a little bit higher no
there's a dividing line duty takes
precedence over everything else or else
it's not a moral point of view right
so he says nature from this point of
view is completely devoid of
independence an essential being so now
Hegel then goes on and says the moral
view of the world so we really have a
third term here we have the the morality
we have nature and then we have the
moral view of the world the moral view
of the world consists contains he says
the development of the moments which are
present in this relation so this is just
a starting point this is this dichotomy
that we're drawing is not the end this
is not Hegel's fully developed position
this is where we're beginning now what
are we beginning from notice how he's
talking about this the moments that are
present in this relation but see hung of
such completely conflicting
presuppositions for all sets on these
these are each presupposing things about
the other and getting it wrong so we're
going to go further than this
to begin with then the moral
consciousness is such is presupposed
duty is the essence for this
consciousness which is actual and active
and in its actuality in action fulfills
its duty but this moral consciousness is
at the same time faced with the
presupposed freedom of nature in other
words it learns from experience that
nature is not concerned with giving the
moral consciousness a sense of the unity
of its reality with that of nature and
hence that nature perhaps may let it
become happy or perhaps may not the non
moral consciousness on the other hand
finds perhaps by chance its realization
where are the moral consciousness is
only an occasion for acting but does not
see itself obtaining through its action
the happiness of performance and the
enjoyment of achievement
therefore it finds rather cause for
complaint about such a state of
incompatibility between itself and
existence and about the injustice which
restricts it to having its object merely
as a pure duty but refuses to let it see
the object and itself realized
here in paragraph 601 Hegel is now going
to spell out for us in a little bit more
detail or at least in general outline
this conflict between morality or duty
on the one hand as something that really
is absolute and essential and the entire
domain of nature which not only includes
what is outside of us but permeates us
as well insofar as we are part of nature
and I'm actually going to use an example
here not one that Hegel himself brings
up but one that I think is very common
in our own time and rather illustrative
of exactly the sort of conflict that he
is talking about at this point so let's
go to the text he says to begin with the
moral consciousness as such is
presuppose for aus Cosette's
right we just saw in the last paragraph
Hegel talking about these two rival
presuppositions outs because that song
opposed to each other and then we also
have the freedom of nature which is
going to be presupposed as well
presupposed here means that something
has set this out right before I was
Cosette's
set it down as here's where we're
starting from it's not to say well
because it's a presupposition it's no
good or anything like that we have to
begin from presuppositions so Hegel says
we presuppose the moral consciousness
and how can we characterize this says
Duty is the essence we began by this
chapter the section by talking about
duty as being the essence the vase and
for this consciousness which is actual
vehicle eeka and active Tett lika
meaning it's it's something that is real
and does things this is usually what
we're striving for in the Hegelian
dialectic isn't it we go from the ideal
to the actual from what is merely a
agender brought on the scene or in
outline to something that is actually
concretely developed so the moral
consciousness is in fact actual but it's
not actual enough and it is active but
it's not active in the right way yet how
so let's let's look so he says in its
actuality and its action it fulfills its
duty that's good that is being in touch
with its essence so I follow the rules
that I ought to because they are in fact
moral rules and they express how I ought
to behave as a decent human being I do
that and I can say I have indeed
fulfilled my duty there's a certain
satisfaction that comes with that
well what's missing then ah here's where
we get to what always makes morality so
complicated you can't pointed this out
if we were you know perfect beings we
almost wouldn't need morality we just go
along with it almost like clockwork or
like you know following certain
algorithms but we're not we're messy
we're involved with nature so he goes on
he says this moral consciousness is at
the same time faced with the presupposed
freedom of nature in other words it
learns from experience it experiences
and thereby acquires this knowledge in a
foreign is the verb there it learns from
experience nature and I'm gonna
paraphrase Nature doesn't care at all
nature Hegel says is not concerned with
giving the moral consciousness a sense
of the unity of its reality with that of
nature that is what moral consciousness
is attempting to bring about is some
sort of unity of its reality with nature
nature's not going to provide that as a
matter of fact nature is going to
provide the opposite experience to the
poor moral consciousness so he says
nature here's a one object lesson nature
may perhaps let it be happy or perhaps
may not so you know doing your duty this
is what Kant had called eudaimonia sztyc
ethics and he thought that pretty much
most of the ethics before him fell into
this you die monistic problematic you
know you say well why should I be a good
person well because in some way the
universe or nature is going to reward
you by doing so and and some people
conceived of this in very sensuous terms
like hey I'll be a good guy and then
I'll go to heaven and God will give me
all sorts of nice things up there or
I'll at least avoid the bad place you
know and I won't burn forever you know
however else you imagine a terrible
afterlife right now put that sort of
stuff aside let's get this stuff that's
a little bit more plausible from a moral
point of view I should be a good person
why because I'm part of a society and if
I behave in a good way
towards other people I'll build up a
certain amount of trust and they will
you know reciprocally behave in a good
way towards me and everyone will you
know be helping each other out well is
that necessarily the case nature and now
don't think is just about like the
natural world think about our human
nature think about the ways in which
human beings behave in relation to each
other about economic about sociological
about psychological laws or at least
generalizations I mean we if this was
the case we wouldn't have what's called
the free rider problem which is that
many people will indeed follow the rules
and behave like good people and then
there's gonna be some jerk who's gonna
ride for free on the subway and not pay
his fare and everyone else is gonna have
to suck it up because of him you know
there if you have insurance your rates
go up not just because of what you did
or what happened to you but because of
some other dummy doing something stupid
that drives us buddies rates up and we
go on and on I mean this can be
summarized you might say in that that
catchphrase this is why we can't have
good things so that's also survey you
die monistic point of view what about
another one what if we take something
that's more Aristotelian or more stoic
or more Cartesian and we say listen we
need to develop ourselves develop our
human nature within ourselves become
virtuous and if we do that then we're
actually going to be happy as a result
Conte said no you might not in fact be
happy following what's rational is is
not guaranteed to satisfy your desires
and inclinations which is what happiness
consistent for cons it's not going to
make you glue click to use the the
German term that Hegel uses here and
Conte says you died monistic ethics this
is the problem with them now you know we
don't have to hash out whether he's
correct about that or not because what
we're looking at is a point of view that
does see things that way and realizes
that the universe or the way things are
set up is not going to pay out for
having done the right thing it's not
going to make you happy
in that sense since nature may let it
become happy or perhaps may not and then
he says the non moral consciousness
another consciousness being brought on
the scene finds perhaps by chance the
real is its realization where the moral
consciousness sees only an occasion for
acting handled in this case is the word
acting there but does not see itself
obtaining through its action then notice
what he says here the happiness of
performance the you know [ __ ] of house
food Iran of doing the thing or the
satisfaction of the good news of
fulfillment fall behind on bringing
things to their proper conclusion
modifying the world in such a way that
the good is thereby produced now this is
a very important point I want to stress
this here Hegel is not just talking
about the fact that you're not going to
get a reward
word for being virtuous from nature that
nature could actually screw you over for
doing that you know smack you in the
face for being a good person but you
don't even control whether you're able
to accomplish the good things that you
set out to accomplish regardless of
whatever reward you would get this is a
bit deeper you know when we say virtue
is its own reward or the fulfillment of
Duty is its own satisfaction
Hegel's saying that maybe it's not that
that maybe nature even controls this now
that is a much deeper idea isn't it so
he says the moral consciousness does not
see itself obtaining through its action
these two things therefore he says it
finds cause for complaint about such a
state of incompatibility between itself
and existence it says what the hell you
know I'm doing the right thing I don't
need the rewards like you know fame and
fortune and people calling me a great
guy or any of that I just want to
actually be able to do the right thing
and see it through and then have the the
the good results not even for me but
just for the world you know happened as
a consequence and I can't even have that
that's like that's a big complaint right
there isn't it and some people have
built entire philosophies on that basis
so he says he sees this as an
incompatibility he also complains about
the injustice which restricts it to
having its object merely as a pure duty
but refuses to let it see the object the
object the duty what the duty commands
and itself fully realized very
interesting idea now I'm going to bring
up an example of this that Hegel does
not cover but which I think may in fact
bring this home to some people listening
to this commentary and this is going to
be controversial
nice guys the guys who behave in a
what they conceived of as a shiver
shiver loose or decent manner towards
women who they view with a sort of
friendship but also may view with a
growing romantic interest they think if
I just behave like a good guy you know
if I'm there to listen if I help her out
when when she needs a ride somewhere
if I act as the white knight and go on
and on and on then sooner or later she's
gonna recognize what a great guy I am
and that I do in fact fulfill duties to
the the person who I am attracted to or
would like to be in a relationship with
and it doesn't work out that way right
and there is a huge like like there's a
world there's actually like a you know
Delta and showering and a world of
complaint that goes along with this I
did the right things
why didn't she treat me nice why didn't
she reciprocate why didn't she reward me
you're basically saying why didn't
nature give me what it is that I wanted
out of the transaction or the equation
and in doing so you're turning Duty into
something like button pushing push the
right buttons in the right sequence I
should get the the reward the candy bar
though whatever it is at the bottom
nature says I don't care what the hell
you do I'm set up the way I am I
actually have a certain kind of freedom
and independence of your views on how
things ought to work and you might say
well what about the really really nice
guy the one who puts those sorts of
things aside and says I just want to do
what's good for this this person I want
to help out the you know woman who I see
an abusive relationship and steer her
towards some therapy that would help her
she might not cooperate with you at all
the world might not cooperate with you
at all you might be the one with the
restraining order filed against you or
is something like that or ghosted or a
cut off there's nothing that says that
just because you feel that you have
some sort of duty and it may in fact be
a genuine duty that the world or nature
somehow has to see things your way and
reward you for attempting to fulfill it
we could come up with many other
examples as well think about parents and
their children
I too so much for my child I sacrifice
and then they wind up like this
well freedom of nature so we could come
up with many many examples along these
lines
you